Allah heal.
[Silence]
Allahbarb. Allahbar.
Allahbar. Allah.
Akbar
[Silence]
Ashad.
Ashan
Hayah
Hoolah.
Oh
fell.
[Silence]
Allahbarbah.
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah. for
[Silence]
the Quran.
Quran.
[Silence]
In the name of Allah the gracious, the
merciful. All praise is due to Allah. We
praise him. We seek his help. We seek
his forgiveness and we seek refuge in
Allah from the evil within ourselves and
the evil within our deeds. Whoever Allah
guides, there is none to misguide him.
Whoever Allah leads astray, there is
none to guide him. I testify there is no
god but Allah alone without any partners
and that Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam, peace and blessings be upon
him, is a servant and his messenger.
Allah Almighty has said, "Oh you who
have faith, fear Allah as it is his
right to be feared and do not die unless
you are Muslim." And Allah Almighty has
said, "Fear Allah from whom you ask of
each other and in your family ties for
Allah is ever watchful over you." And
Allah Almighty has said, "Fear Allah and
speak words as befitting. He will amend
your deeds for you and forgive your
sins. Whoever obeys Allah and his
messenger has achieved a great triumph."
The truest word is the book of Allah and
the best guidance is the guidance of
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam. The
most evil matters are those that are
newly invented. For every newly invented
matter is an innovation. Every
innovation is misguidance and every
misguidance is in the hellfire. We thank
Allah for letting us come to the masid
on the blessed day of Friday to reap the
benefits and virtues that come with the
day of J.
Where did the time go? The sun hardly
rises before it sets. And it seems like
a day is merely a moment. One minute you
open your eyes and the next is time. And
the new moon hardly appears, then it
disappears. And it seems a month is
just a day. And a year hardly begins
before it ends. And it seems a year
is just a week. And the years have
been passing by so quickly that subhan
Allah, we're just left in astonishment.
Where did the time go? Yeah, it's been
around 5 years since a global pandemic.
I don't know if I'm the only one who
thinks that just insane. So many things
have happened in the year 2019 to 2020,
even 2021. And to think that four to 5
years have passed since then, subhan
Allah, it's just mind-blowing. We're
halfway through 2025 as well. And time
passing quickly this, we all know
it's among the signs of the hour. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam has
said,
Now the hour shall not be established
until time is constricted. And the year
is a month. A month is the
week and the week is the day and
the day is the hour and the hour is
the flare of a fire.
And in many instances the Quran and
Sunnah indicate the fleeting nature of
this worldly life as well. In the Quran
Allah mentions the fleeting dunya. Often
the time of their account has approached
for people while they are in heatless
turning away. They are heedless in
turning away while their time of account
is near. And he also says,
"And what makes you perceive? Perhaps
the hour is near." And then Allah goes
more specifically into this.
And the command for the hour is not but
a glance of the eye or even nearer than
that. Indeed Allah is over all things
competent. And the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam has said
my advent meaning my arrival and the
hour are this. And he would point
his two fingers together this. He
would point his two fingers together.
That's how close his arrival and the
hour are. And we've all heard this
before how the hour is coming close and
the dunya will soon to end. And Allah
describes the attachment to this very
fleeting world water.
The example of this worldly life is but
rain which we have sent down from
the sky that the plants of the earth
absorb and from those plants mankind and
livestock eat. And then he goes on
[Silence]
until when the earth has taken on its
adorment meaning all these beautiful
green shrubs and these and these amazing
plants for the mankind and the lifestyle
to eat and when they insan they think
they have capability over it. They think
they have power. They think they have
authority over these green shrubs, over
these plants. Then our command comes and
we make it as if it didn't even flourish
yesterday. That's how quickly it can
change.
who give thought and subhan Allah this
great example is repeated inah
and surah had the worldly life is like
water that nurtures crops and the water
either seeps into the earth or
evaporates and it doesn't remain
likewise the worldly life vanishes and
ends water does not stay in one place
and similarly the beauty of this world
it doesn't remain with anyone forever
it's bound to end when water comes down
in an amount that benefits the earth It
vibrates with greenery and benefits the
living. However, if the water is
excessive, it floods the land. It
destroys the crops and it kills people.
And likewise, if a person takes from
this worldly life enough to sustain
himself enough to help them on their
journey to their Lord Almighty and then
they benefit from it, then they can
truly benefit from this dunya because
they made the world a means to the
hereafter. They made the dunya a
stepping stool to the hereafter. But if
someone is greedy and they spend all
their life accumulating and enjoying in
this worldly life and they overtake,
they take too much, it destroys them as
they try to replace the hereafter.
Therefore, it is said that the love of
the world is the root of all sins. And
this worldly life was likened to the
lush green land. For it becomes green
and beautiful and then it turns yellow
and becomes dusty. and its beauty fades
away. Similarly, the delights of this
world deceive those who look at it.
You'll look at the world, you'll marvel
at its beauty at first because
everything looks so beautiful.
Everything shines and then once you keep
looking at it, once you get accustomed
to it, once you get attached to it, then
it all goes away either through a
calamity that spoils it or death that
cuts off its pleasure. And thus it is
described in the Quran that the
enjoyment of this world is the enjoyment
of deception.
And what is this worldly life except the
enjoyment of delusion?
On top of the deceiving nature of this
worldly life, a person only lives a
small fraction of it. Even if someone
mashallah were to live for a 100red
years, that still wouldn't be enough. No
matter how long one lives in this world,
even if it were 100, a thousand years,
it will seem at the time of death, at
the time of resurrection and the time of
reckoning. And they will think all these
times at the time of death,
resurrection, and reckoning. And they'll
think back on the dunya, and it will be
as if they only live for a moment.
That's how insignificant this duny is.
Allah Almighty has said,
And on the day when he will gather them,
it will be as if they had not remained
in the world but an hour of the day they
will know each other. How many years do
we live? Let's say at the best best case
scenario 100 years and in the hereafter
we'll be it was only an hour.
That's how it will feel and only an
hour.
Allah will say how long did you remain
on the earth in a number of years? Give
me a number of years. How long you lived
on this earth? And they will say we
remained a day, maybe a part of a day.
We don't know. Ask those who enumerate.
Meaning we didn't keep track of how long
we lived in this world. Ask those who
kept track. We just lived and we moved
on. That's how that's how insignificant
it is.
And on the day when they see it, it will
be on that day they had not remained in
the world except for a morning or an
afternoon.
you come over to someone's house
for breakfast and then you move on.
That's how insignificant the world is.
That's how short it will be. And the
messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, the most knowledgeable of
people about this worldly life and its
reality said,
By Allah,
the world compared to the hereafter is
nothing more than what happens when
you dip your finger into the sea. Let
him see what he draws out. What happens
if you dip dip your finger into the sea?
You dip it in, it comes out, two drops
come out and whatever's left, that's the
dunya. And that dries away in a matter
of moments. That is how insignificant
this dunya is. The believer should take
heed from these verses and a hadith that
clarify the reality of this world and
the duration of human existence within
it. Especially since they frequently
encounter these verses when reciting and
listening to the Quran. Therefore,
believers should not make this worldly
life their greatest concern or allow
their love for it to corrupt their
hearts.
Instead, the believers should take from
it what helps them obey Allah the
Almighty and strive to purify their soul
with righteous deeds. In this lie
success and prosperity, as Allah
Almighty has said,
he who has succeeded has purified it,
meaning the dunya. And he has failed who
instills it with corruption. his heart
with the dunya.
We ask Allah to make us among those who
realize the fleeting nature of this
worldly life and to not be deceived by
the enjoyment of delusion and to invest
in the hereafter.
And that brings me on to the next point
which is that no matter how long someone
were to live in this dunya even if let's
say you live the 80 years they will
never be satisfied.
Look at the famous. Look at the rich.
Look at the powerful. Look at the
celebrities. Everyone knows that those
people who have sold their souls to the
entertainment and the pleasure of the
dunya while forgetting the hereafter,
they are all miserable.
People say money can't buy you
happiness. And you look around and some
people they look happy. You look at the
celebrities with their Bugattis, their
Ferraris, their Mercedes. You look at
them with their yachts and their private
islands. You look at them with their
butlers and everything. They have their
designer clothes and they're smiling in
their pictures on Instagram and whatnot.
They look happy. They look happy.
The truth is money can't buy you
contentment. Being serenely calm, being
happy, actually happy without having to
worry about that is going to end. Being
calm, being content,
that is something that you can only
achieve in the hereafter. That's not
something you can achieve in this.
No matter how hard you strive for it,
you can't achieve it in this. True,
serene, calm, contentment, that comes in
the
And even if someone were to live
forever. And that's another thing I'd
to bring up. People wish they could
live for years and years and years,
don't they? They think, "Oh, I'm going
to have to die soon. I wish I could live
for longer. I wish I had a healthy, a
longer life." But ask someone logical.
Ask someone with a mind. Would you like
to live forever? No. Why? Why would
someone not to live forever?
Because they know they will eventually
get tired of the dunya. No matter how
much you have, you will get tired of the
dunya. Let's say in this hypothetical,
this person who lives forever, has
immense wealth, they have immense
amounts of everything they could ever
possibly have. Even if they have that,
they will watch their family and loved
ones pass away. They will watch the
collapse of the world. They will watch
the collapse of the nations. They will
go through pain and heartbreak through
trials and tribulations. Suppose they
age as well. They will go through the
whole aging process breaking down and
becoming a husk of who they once was.
And at the end of the universe, they
will still be there because no matter
what the dunya is meant to end. Allah
has promised it. And we all know the
promise of Allah is true. Lifespans are
finite for a reason. And death
demolishes the pleasures of this worldly
life. No one can repent. No one can
prevent, repel or postpone death. If you
love this world so much,
then prevent death from yourselves.
Allah challenges you. Prevent death from
yourselves if you can. If you should be
truthful,
wherever you may be, death will overtake
you. Even if you should be in the
highest of lofty constructions, even if
you should be in giant buildings or if
you're in castles,
death will overtake you. Subhan Allah.
Look at this powerful wording.
It's a reality that no one can deny.
Muslims, Jews, Christians, the atheists,
no matter what, this is a reality of the
world. Even if someone doesn't believe
even the they know that the is bent to
end
every soul will taste death. Every soul
shall taste death. Then to us you'll be
returned.
Allah Almighty has said
say indeed the death from which you flee
indeed it will meet you. It is 100%
guaranteed. You can flee from death all
you want. You can try to run away from
death all you want. It will meet you.
Death will meet you. And when that time
comes when you die, what will we bring?
We won't be bringing any of our wealth.
We won't be bringing the enjoyments of
this duny. We won't be bringing anything
that we worked for in this dunya. The
job that we work so hard for. I'm sorry,
but the bitter truth is when you die, it
becomes obsolete.
The money that we love, the spouses that
we love, the children that we love, the
parents that we love, the friends that
we love, nothing, none of it will make
it into the grave except for what you
worked for in the
only make it into the grave. And when we
make into the grave, the only physical
thing we will bring with us is our
bodies and our cuff. The white sheet
that will be wrapped around our bodies
for us to be buried in. That is it. In
fact, you're not taking the coffin with
you. The cuff is taking you into the
grave.
You're bound to that white cloth
helpless. And it's only then that in the
grave that we have ample time to think
about how we spent our life. And it will
be in that grave that we can think where
did the time go. May Allah make us of
those who remember him often and cling
to the instead of the
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Throughout the Quran and Sunnah and the
hadith, we hear many times for us to
focus on the instead of the to give up
the for the and this is true. But I also
want to reiterate that as a Muslim, we
are not meant to hate the dunya. Do not
hate the duny. Do not be depressed
because you live in the dunya. Do not
resent the dunya. For Allah has made
halal and things for us to enjoy.
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam has
said from this world he loved perfume,
prayer and women. And Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam had favorite
foods. He liked sweet water made from
dates. And he liked eating the shoulders
of animals. We're meant to enjoy what's
halal of this dunya. a traveler
enjoys the shade during his journey.
That's it. Nothing more, nothing less.
We should remember to keep a balance and
not to get attached with the dunya.
We're meant to resent the attachment to
the delusions of the dunya. And we
should focus on the the everlasting life
of the hereafter. We should give up the
delusions and the attachment to the and
the trials of the world because if we
grow attached to them, we end up selling
our the more you love the the more it
will break your heart especially when
you have to let it go. Chasing the
it doesn't mean live in a cave and it
doesn't mean you give up your job. No,
it means for example you pray your five
daily prayers on time. You treat your
parents withan with honor. You keep your
tongues moist with the with the
remembrance of Allah. You seek halal
wealth and you give from it in. You
lower your gaze. You forgive those who
wrong you. And you control your desires
because you know Allah is watching. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam has
said be in this world as though you are
a traveler or a stranger. And and a
traveler he doesn't build a mansion at a
rest stop. He rests and moves on. This
dunya is your resting stop. It's your
resting place. Jenna is your
destination. Jenna is your destination.
So walk through the dunya, but keep your
eyes on the hereafter. Use every minute,
every dollar, every word, and every
breath as a way to earn Allah's
pleasure. I want to share with you a
story that was the inspiration for this
topic. A story that would provide as an
inspiration and an example of someone
who understood how much value that and
the pleasure of Allah and his prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam had compared
to his dunya. A story of a man named
a story of a man who started with
everything and left with nothing.
He was one of the most famous and
wealthy people in the city of Mecca. He
came from a prestigious family. luxuries
left, right and center. And he was one
of the most handsome men in the city of
Mecca. When he walked through the city
place, people would line up just to
glance at him. That's how handsome he
was. And when he would walk by some
place, people would know that he had
recently been there because of how
expensive his perfume was. Meaning that
himself as a person, his aura, his
upbringing, his lifestyle, it was that
of a prince. His clothes were custom
made, imported from Syria. His shoes
were imported from Yemen and his mother
and his family was from a similar
status. He had everything he would ever
ask for. And one day he heard about a
man preaching an faith and he was like
what is this? This is the opposite of
what our forefathers taught us. And he
was interested. So he went to meet with
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
himself and he went to the place where
the early Muslims were residing and he
heard the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam speaking about jannam
and he was speaking about this very
topic the fleeting dunya and the
delusions and the distractions of this
world that drag people into hell and
from hearing that alone
he gave his right
And from then on, he kept visiting again
and again to the house, sneaking out and
practicing his faith privately because
at this time the Muslims were
persecuted.
And he kept practicing until one day a
spy had followed him and saw him
practicing Islam. So he went straight to
his mother and said, "Do you know what
your son is doing? Do you know what he's
doing? He's practicing this faith." So
his mother was filled with anger. And
what she did, she paid a few guards and
had him chained up in her basement in
the cellar. And from the cellar,
he heard about a migration to
Abbiscinia. And so he waited until one
night when the guards were sleeping and
he made a run for it. And he ran all the
way to where the migration was taking
place. And he made it to Abbiscinia. And
in Abbisinia, he heard a rumor that all
of Becca had converted to Islam. Of
course, this rumor was false, but he
learned the hard way because he came
back and that's where he found out. And
when he met his mother, his mother told
him, "Yeah,
come back to your life. Come back to me.
Come back to your clothes. Come back to
your decad in life. Come back to your
status. Come back to your honor." Yeah,
there are many instances where we are
practicing our faith and the dunya makes
its way it lodges its way into our
practicing. Of course, not in this exact
scenario. There are smaller scales, but
people they want money, they want fun,
and usually that ends up showing its
ugly head while you're at your strongest
of iman.
And subhan Allahb he was very strong of
faith and so he denied his mother his
old life and out of anger she would tear
off all the clothes off his back leaving
him with literally nothing. He had to
walk away using his hands to cover
himself. It was only when his uncle had
pity on him that he gave him a small
cloth to cover himself with.
And the Sahabah when they used to look
at Musb they used to weep because they
knew who he was. He used to be someone
who would wear long lengthy robes and
fancy perfume and now he was wearing
this cheap wool garment that would leave
sores on his body and he used to weep
and subhan Allah the reason I'm telling
you this is because this is one of the
most prominent examples of someone
giving away their dy for the and it's
not he gave it up in vain no Allah
honored him and subhan Allah I urge you
when you get home to read the story of
Musabb because subhan Allah his story it
is so inspirational it is such an
amazing story and I urge all of you to
read the story of Musabb
but I'll give you one final anecdote
from his story how Allah honored him
with martyrdom
we all know what happened at the battle
of Bahad
we all know how it started and Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam during this
battle He wanted someone to carry the
flag of And now who was a Muslim at this
time?
They were all Muslim.
But Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
he chose this young boy.
That's number one. how Allah honored him
with this flag of
now we all know what mistake happened at
a at the battle of the archers they left
their post the disbelievers they came
back he attacked the the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and he was
rumored to be dead and when news came to
Mus he didn't wallow many of the
Muslims who decided they were putting
down their swords you know we give up
the prophet's dead mus he said the
messengers before him have died as
He was strong of faith. He was strong of
iman.
And then the rumor came that the prophet
was alive and he was surrounded. So what
he did was he held the flag of in his
right hand and he started running around
the battlefield his right hand raised
shouting Allahbarb
come fight me come fight me. So the
attention would be taken off the
prophet. And someone came and they
lobbed off his right arm. So what did he
do? He grabbed the flag with his left
arm, raised it up in the air, started
running around. Allah abar, come fight
me. Come fight me. Someone came and they
lobbed off the left arm as well. He bent
down, he picked up the flag with his
teeth and he started running across the
battlefield
with the flag between his teeth.
And at this point, the goof were
obviously tired of this distraction.
and they hit him and they speared him
and they slashed his body until he
finally fell.
After the battle had concluded, the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
surveyed the battlefield and he asked
where is Hamza? Where is so and so?
Where is so and so? Until he came upon a
body and he began to weep. This was the
body of Musbay.
His face had been disfigured by the
kufur. They cut off his nose and his
ears.
But one thing they did find was the flag
was still between his teeth.
He did not abandon his faith. He did not
abandon his duty. The flag was still
between his teeth. And the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he wept for
him saying, "You gave everything for the
sake of Allah." And when it came time to
bury his body, they found he had only
two belongings.
a bowl for woo and half of a cuff. He
was too poor to afford a full cuff. When
they'd cover his head, his feet would
stick out. And when they covered his
feet, his head would stick out. Finally,
they decided, we'll cover his head and
we'll cover his feet in lemongrass and
then we'll bury him right there. Yeah. I
want to remind you who this man was. He
had everything in the dunya. Every
single thing you would ask for. wealth,
looks, honor, status.
He had everything. He had so much money.
And now he didn't even have enough money
to be buried in. He didn't even have
enough money to die in.
Only half of awan and he barely made it
to adulthood. We wouldn't consider him
an adult nowadays.
We would consider him a teenager. that
his life short-lived will be remembered
and honored because he gave it to Allah.
He gave his life to Allah and this is
what Allah decided to do with it. He
honored him. We ask Allah to make us of
those who remember him often. We ask
Allah to make us of those who focus on
the and enjoy what he has given us in
the duny. We ask Allah to remove our
unhealthy attachment to the dunya. We
ask Allah to make us clear- minded and
to keep our priorities straight. We ask
Allah to guide us and make the path to
the smooth and easy. We ask Allah to
forgive all of our shortcomings. We ask
Allah to dismay any sins we may commit
knowingly or unknowingly. We ask Allah
to have mercy on us on our parents and
their parents as well. We ask Allah to
grant us the highest levels of paradise
without any accountability. We ask Allah
to guide all those who are not Muslim to
guide those who are drowning in sin. We
ask Allah to protect us from living a
life of sin. We ask Allah to conceal and
hide any sins we may have committed in
the past knowingly or unknowingly and to
conceal and hide any sins we will commit
in the future. We ask Allah to not let
him take us from this earth until he is
pleased with us. We ask Allah when the
time comes of our death our souls are
extracted from our bodies peacefully. We
ask Allah to make it so our last words
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Strain the lines. Fill the gaps in
between. Do not leave space for
alhamdulillah.
foreign.
[Silence]
for
All
[Silence]
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
Allah
sir Allah
You don't believe
Allahel.
Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Oh,
send me a
Allah.
Allah
Allahel.
[Silence]
All
right, just a couple of announcement and
we'll dismiss. Just I want you to
really pay attention to the driving
patterns that are outside the masjid.
The first entrance that you see that's
turning into the masid is an exit. It's
not an entrance. I don't know how many
times I can, you know, be very,
you know, prun about and remind you be
careful. There is a tendency within the
parking lot for people to fly out. If
you're entering and turning into it with
full speed and there's a car coming from
the opposite side, you're going to
definitely meet each other halfway
through.
The second past the palm tree with the
island, that is the entrance. That is
not the exit. The exit is the first
entrance a lot of you are using as
entrance.
And it's you think it's a very
convenient thing to do. Just please be
attentive. It is a problematic. The
alley behind them is an exit only. It's
not an entrance or a two-way street. Be
mindful of that. There are several signs
up that remind you of that. So, be
careful and please pay attention in the
parking lot. , I want to thank Haf
Talha for being part of a community for
a while. Tala is moving to Colorado. ,
he said it's a beautiful weather and the
mountains look much better with snow
than they do with dust. So, I don't
know. Inshallah we wish him all the best
on his future endeavors and with his
family. Inshallah we have a small
partying gift for our MCCT fatal. Please
take this as a small gesture of our
appreciation for your time that you
spent and the efforts you have made in
the community. May Allah make it a
beautiful transition. May Allah open
more doors for you. Come back soon. All
right.
donate generously on the way out. I
want you to pay attention that when you
went walk outside there is a tree of
gratitude that's been put up. Those are
from the students from the summer
school the Sunday school that translates
to summer school. We still have a week
or so left. If you're interested in your
childhood being there, those are some of
the activities the kids do on a daily
basis. Enjoy the gratitude tree.